[Music]
welcome back so this next video in our
series on the Fourier series is going to
talk about how we generalize from
periodic functions periodic on domains -
L - L - the Fourier transform which is
defined on an infinite domain okay so
just a very very short recap the Fourier
series idea is that for an arbitrary
function f of X that's periodic on some
domain in this case I've chosen - L to L
so it's a - L periodic function f of X
you can expand f as a sum of sines and
cosines that are essentially also
periodic and 2l and higher and higher
harmonics of those basic sines and
cosines you can represent this as a
complex Fourier series where you have
this function e to the I K PI x over L
okay
and these CK's are the Fourier
coefficients that are obtained by
projecting my function f into each of
these orthogonal function directions
given by e to the ikx over L okay and if
you expanded this out you would get
cosines plus AI signs at these
frequencies okay so in fact this defines
a frequency Omega K equals I want to
call it K PI over L K PI over L okay so
for each K you essentially get cosines
and sines with this basic basic
frequency okay and I'm defining this
function e to the ikx over L to be
called sy okay okay so that's that's
Fourier series we've covered this we've
talked all about this but I do want to
point something out that because each of
these functions is - L periodic
essentially if you look to the left or
to the right of - L and L what you find
is that this function will repeat itself
forever so oh I guess this is three L
and then five L it would keep going
negative three L and so on and so forth
forever okay so this
or a series representation is actually
2l periodic and so essentially what it
does is it gives you a tiling of this f
of X defined from minus L to L and it
just repeats itself every to L to the
left and to the right forever good okay
not not too complicated and you can't
get anything else if you're using these
periodic functions okay to approximate f
but what if you want to actually
approximate this pointy hat function but
you assume that this pointy hat function
actually goes on being zero forever okay
so I'm gonna say to infinity and to -
minus infinity here okay and so that's
what the Fourier transform is gonna do
so the Fourier series gives you these
these periodic functions what the
Fourier transform is it's very very
simple before you transform is simply a
Fourier series as I tell take L goes to
infinity okay so that's all we're gonna
do for this lecture we're gonna take
this representation of the Fourier
series and I'm just gonna take L goes to
infinity okay and what that's going to
give us is a representation of this
function where it's no longer periodic
forever but if it is zero at some point
it stays zero at that point or whatever
you can represent arbitrary functions
from negative infinity to infinity
with this Fourier transform okay and
that's what we're gonna do so a couple
of things that you're gonna see we're
gonna take L goes to infinity and what
that means is that this this frequency I
want to say that this is equal to K
Delta Omega where Delta Omega is PI over
L okay and so as we take the limit as L
goes to infinity what we're going to see
is that this Delta Omega is going to go
to zero so our little the resolution
with which we can resolve different
frequencies is going to become
infinitesimally small and this is going
to become a de Omega okay
and this sum is going to become a
Riemann integral so that's what we're
gonna we're gonna do right now okay good
this actually isn't too bad these bounds
are going to go from minus infinity to
infinity
and so on and so forth so I'm just going
to write this out that my f of X for my
Fourier transform and I'm going to use a
different color here so f of X for my
Fourier transform is and the limit as L
goes to infinity is the same as the
limit as Delta Omega goes to 0 okay goes
to 0 so as L goes to infinity Delta
Omega goes to 0 so I'm going to use
those interchangeably so I'm gonna say
that this is the limit as Delta Omega
goes to 0 of this sum here okay my son
from K equals minus infinity to infinity
and now I'm gonna take this expression
for my my Fourier coefficient and I'm
gonna plug it in for C K ok so that's 1
over 2 L is the same as Delta Omega over
2 pi Delta Omega over 2 pi that's just 1
over 2 L integral ok now - L - L is the
same as minus PI over Delta Omega 2 PI
over Delta oh my god remember taking the
limit as this goes to zero so this will
go to negative infinity and plus
infinity good of all of this stuff so
that's F of and I'm gonna introduce a
dummy variable C F of C e to the minus I
K Delta Omega X ok so that's minus I K
Delta Omega C because I'm using my dummy
variable C deke C ok that all of this
stuff right here is just my Fourier
coefficients C K and I have to multiply
this whole thing by e to the I K PI x
over L which is e to the I K
Delta Omega X okay so this all I've done
all I'm doing here is I'm taking my for
a series I'm plugging in my coefficient
CK which is this projection here I'm
plugging all of this CK in and I'm
taking the limit as my frequency
resolution becomes infinitely fine or if
you like as L goes to infinity they're
the same thing so I'm taking the limit
as L goes to infinity this is the same
as L goes to infinity or the limit as
Delta Omega goes to 0 okay and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna we're
gonna analyze this expression what we're
gonna find is that if you take Delta
Omega goes to 0 this sum over width
Delta Omega is going to become a riemann
integral okay this is going to become an
integral with a d omega out here and i'm
actually I'm just going to write this
out okay so this is going to equal this
is the riemann integral the let me try
to write this out so this is an integral
from negative infinity to infinity
i'm going to move my delta omega over
here and it's going to become a d omega
so i'm going to get a 1 over 2 pi
integral from again negative infinity to
infinity this is just negative infinity
to infinity of f c/e to the I now K
Delta Omega is just Omega so e to the I
Omega C and there's a minus here DX e
times e to the plus I Omega X and then
this is going to be a D Omega ok so
that's all that we've done is we've
taken our Fourier series with our
coefficients we plug them all into a big
expression and we've taken the limit as
L goes to infinity or Delta Omega goes
to 0 ok and when we rewrite this this
son becomes a Riemann integral
okay so this is an integral of these
things here ok and this is integrated
with respect to some dummy variable see
this isn't it graded with respect to my
frequency Omega ok and so what's really
cool about this is now I can start
pulling this integral apart and I can
say that this whole expression here this
whole expression here actually let me
let me make it ah let me just include
everything up to this integral so this
whole expression here I'm going to say
that that is just the inner product of F
with respect to that basis function okay
so this is I'm just gonna call this this
function here these are my Fourier
coefficients these are my Fourier
coefficients I take my function of space
f of X and I integrate X out okay and
all that's left is a function of Omega
this is a function of frequency so I'm
gonna call this f hat of Omega okay
that's my Fourier transform F hat and I
get this is my Fourier transform and
then all of this stuff is my inverse
Fourier transform it takes me back to f
of X okay so I want to write this out
nice and clean so that you see it and
then and then we'll start analyzing
properties of this Fourier transform
okay good so let me just write this out
f hat I'm gonna say f hat is a function
of Omega it's a function of these
continuum of frequencies that we're
gonna use now now we have a continuum of
frequencies of sines and cosines we're
going to add up to approximate this
function and that F of Omega is going to
be given by we define this as the
Fourier transform of f of X that's what
I mean by this curly F here okay Fourier
transform of f of X and that equals the
integral from minus infinity to infinity
of f of X and I want to get my sign
right eetu the minus I Omega X DX so
that's all I have to do if I want to
compute the Fourier transform I take my
function f of X and I integrate from
minus infinity to infinity with respect
to x times the function e to the I Omega
X okay and all of these X's integrate
out and I just get a function of Omega
so this is these are my Fourier
coefficients this is the Fourier
transform these
exactly analogous to my CK's but now
this is a continuous function instead of
having a discrete set a discrete
infinite set of function C K now I have
a whole continuum of Fourier
coefficients in this F hat this is the
Fourier transform and then if I take
this F hat if I just replace all of this
with f hat this function this formula
tells me how to get back to my original
function f of X okay so f of X and we're
gonna call this the inverse Fourier
transform this is F negative 1 of F hat
of Omega so if I have an F hat Omega
function if someone gives me the Fourier
transform coefficients I can inverse
Fourier transform to get f of X by this
integral here 1 over 2 pi integral again
minus infinity to infinity of F hat
Omega and now I multiply it by e to the
plus I Omega X and I integrate with
respect to Omega so similarly all of my
omegas integrate out and I get a
function and X back ok so really cool if
I have a function of F if I have this
function of f that's defined from
negative infinity to infinity then I can
define the Fourier transform by this
integral expression here and I get a
continuous function of Fourier
coefficients which is a function of
frequencies these omegas are just like
the frequencies of my sines and cosines
here but they're continuously varying I
can have any frequency not just these
integer multiples of PI over L ok
similarly if I have those Fourier
coefficients I can work in either space
I like I can work in in real x space or
I can Fourier transform into frequency
space and when I've done my work in
frequency space I can inverse Fourier
transform according to this formula and
recover my function f of X ok so this is
extremely important this is called the
Fourier transform pair there's a lot of
neat properties of this operator F this
Fourier transform I'll tell you about so
it has really nice properties when I
think about the derivative of F so it's
easy to compute derivatives in Fourier
space in F hat space that just becomes I
a Omega F hat that's the Fourier
transform of F prime I Omega F hat so
it's easy to compute the derivatives of
functions in the Fourier transform
domain which makes it very very useful
for solving differential equations it's
easier for me to solve my partial
differential equations oftentimes in
Fourier space so I take my function I
Fourier transform I saw my differential
equation and then once I have my
solution I inverse Fourier transform
back to my physical space okay very very
important this is the Fourier transform
pair and essentially all that this is
doing is generalizing this notion of a
Fourier series to an infinite sized
domain okay that's all we're doing we're
gonna use this extensively to solve
partial differential equations we're
going to look at its properties this F
is a unitary operator in the space of
functions so that's a very important
property this is a unitary operator
remember the singular value
decomposition gave us unitary matrices
and so a lot of the properties that we
like about SPD's and Fourier transforms
kind of carry over so that that's really
useful okay we're going to talk a lot
more about how you can use this Fourier
transform especially for solving partial
differential equations in the next
lectures thank you